Speaker 1: All right, let's start today with
another bizarre step that active actors are
willing to take despite not wanting to just go
and get the vaccine, which is a known quantity.
There are now people snorting and gargling
iodine, presumably to fight covid-19. This is
a really bad idea. And as is the case with many
of these things, I have no problem telling you
what the kernel of a scientific basis is for
where this came from. And I'll tell you that in a
moment. Here's an article from Men's Health which
says iodine was once a popular treatment for your
typical cut and scratch. And now ActiveX circles
are claiming that gargling or snorting it works as
a preventive for covid-19. Poveda own iodine known
commercially as Betadine, is typically used on the
skin as a first aid treatment or a disinfectant
for surgery prep. Remember, in school, you would
get a cut, you'd go to the nurse's office, they
would put that iodine yellow, the yellow stuff
on it. It would sting and, you know, and then
you would go back to class. Typically, the brand
has also introduced a zero point five percent
mouth rinse meant to treat a mild sore throat,
not to prevent covid. On September 8th, a Twitter
user claiming to be an E.R. doctor tweeted,
and we will show you the tweet. Don't get
covid prophylaxis is not that hard. Also, nasal
spray with a couple of drops Betadine in it and
gargle with original Listerine. So you see here
there are a bunch of things in the picture
which I will describe. There's vitamin C,
there's melatonin. There is I don't know
what that thing in the middle is, zinc,
vitamin D and then adds nasal spray with Betadine
and gargle with original Listerine. Unfortunately,
this is a disinfectant. As William Schaffner,
doctor, professor of preventive medicine
at Vanderbilt, says its use has slowed
down because even on scratches and cuts,
its effectiveness has been debated. There
is no data this would be effective for covid
Avro health. The makers of Betadine has also
intervened in online conversations saying
Betadine, antiseptic, sore throat gargle
is only for temporary relief of occasional
sore throat. It has not been demonstrated to
be effective for the treatment or prevention
of covid-19 or other viruses. So there's a
few things to talk about here. First of all,
there are some studies that have been done which
say that. If you use and it's very speculative
data, but if you use it, let me see how the right
way to apply this is in a Petri dish. If you
use something like an iodine solution, it seems
to reduce the viral level of viral particles.
But again, this is based on in vitro studies
and only for a little bit of time. So
most optimistically, what we
could say right now would be
if you put some of this stuff in your throat and
you have some virus particles in your throat,
but really the virus is in the lungs. Right? It's
possible possible that in in some brief sense,
it would reduce the number of viral
particles in the mouth and throat.
But because it's in the lungs, if the infection
is in the lungs, then within a very short time,
those viral particles are going to reappear
in the throat. What's going on here is that
it's very similar to what happened with hydroxy
chloroquine and ivermectin. Iodine is just around.
It's cheap. It's widely available everywhere. So
much like with hydroxy chloroquine or ivermectin,
it's logical that we would say, does any of the
cheap stuff we already have and that's plentiful
work for covid. And sometimes you'll stumble
across a false efficacy signal. As we saw earlier
with hydroxy chloroquine, you might stumble
across some in vitro study or something like that.
You know, the the the new thing when I go to my
dentist's office is they have me rinse with with
something and all that. You know, my dentist has
it. It seems as though just at a very micro level,
it's possible this might kill some virus
particles in your throat right now. But
if you're infected and it's in the lungs and
you're breathing it in the throat, in the mouth,
are going to refill with it very, very quickly. So
the big picture story here is how are people that
are insanely skeptical of things from verified
sources about known quantities like the vaccine,
willing to accept what random people on Twitter
say and just going and doing it? That's a real
problem. That's a real crisis. And it's a crisis
of education. It's a crisis of media literacy. But
in the meantime, don't snort and or gargle iodine
solution, not something you want to be doing.